c'est une photo qui tourne depuis jeudi
sur les réseaux sociaux et qui risque de
vous faire froid dans le dos celle de ce
jeune garçon à elle âgée de seulement 15
mois et qui a été retrouvé par ses
parents le visage tuméfié
à la sortie de la crèche des hématomes
terribles auxquelles les responsables
n'ont donné aucune véritable explication
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
mais alors que s'est-il vraiment passé
peut-on vraiment faire confiance à ceux
qui ont la garde de nos enfants ce
scandale met-il en lumière un tabou bien
garder au sein des crèches ce soir sofia
sa maman et notre témoin du jour et elle
a décidé d'agir
voilà elle nous a rejoint
c'est notre témoin du jour vous savez
que tous les soirs on a un témoin dans
touche pas à mon poste et ce soit sofia
est avec nous merci d'être là je sais
vous venez de me dire c'est très
difficile vous avez eu alors on va pas
dire on se trouve la crèche que je crois
vous avez eu d'énormes pressions pour ne
pas venir témoigner ce soit d'accord oui
impression de de la création on peut pas
on peut pas de toute façon c'est une
pression ils seront calella et son
excellent quand même donc il n'ya pas de
dire mais vous avez voulu témoigner
parce que ce qui c'est qui est arrivé à
votre enfant
c'était le 23 des sons vous êtes au
travail votre enfant est à la crèche et
bourg chever n'appelle au bout dit quoi
on m'appelle pour me dire de venir
récupérer mon fils pourquoi qu'est ce
qui se passe et on m'explique que
monfils s'est fait mal la voix
tremblante de la directrice adjointe et
là je dis même si c'est fait maintenant
vous pouvez parler bien force convivial
avec le masque désolé je demande c'est
si grave que ça pour venir le récupérer
après une morsure même si c'était déjà
fait mordre une ou deux fois j'avais
déjà prévenu on va dire quelque chose
enfin des choses qui peuvent arriver et
et là au vu de sa voix j'ai compris
qu'il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait
pas donc d'aquin exactement il a quinze
mois j'étais au travail j'ai appelé mon
mari pour lui demander d'aller récupérer
mon fils voilà je ne sachant pas encore
ce qui s'était passé alors vous décidez
donc de venir le récupérer à la crèche
oui bon et là c'est incroyable ce que
vous voyez
ouais bah ouais en fait ça mon mari mon
voit une photo on voit là de mon fils
comme ça c est resté sans voix fin on ne
savait pas quoi faire quoi dire
il a demandé ce qui s'était passé il a
demandé ce qui s'était pas leurs yeux on
nous a expliqué que qui s'était fait
mordre
pendant sa sieste voilà mais j'avoue ma
vie reste est vraiment sans voix savais
pas quoi dire savais pas quoi faire donc
comme moi je lui ai demandé de l'emmener
notre 6 aux urgences on pouvait pas
laisser comme ça sachant que la crèche
n'a rien fait bien sûr n'a pas alors
vous intervenez en plus et c'est ça qui
est très grave
vous apprenez que on vous appelle mais
les faits ils viennent pas d'arriver ils
sont arrivés il y a trois heures donc on
a laissé le petit pendant trois heures à
la crèche comme ça dont les gens sont
occupés et si ça paraît souffrir
bon il dit parce que il devait honorer
mes rêveries donc on vous à vous appeler
trois heures après comment ça se fait je
ne les explique pas je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas me l'expliquer en fait sur le
coup on n'a pas su on nous a pas dit que
ça s'était passé il ya 3 heures on
l'appelle comme ça et en fait j'ai tout
simplement demandé à mon mari mais enfin
donne moi le déroulé de la journée et
qu'elle comptait ce qu'il a mangé est-ce
qu'elle a été qu elles ont été des
siestes les horaires et c est en fait
mon mari m'a dit j'ai même pas pu
demander tellement j'étais perturbé et
tellement ça m'a traumatisée donc du
coup ce que j'ai fait ce que j'ai appelé
la crèche et j'ai demandé en fait les
transmissions de la journée donc le
déroulé de la journée alors et les
explications qui ont été donnés à mon
mari sait que c'est que c'est que n'at
elle s'était fait mordre pendant le
temps de sieste et là on me dit que mon
fils dans les transmissions a dormi de
12h30 à 13h30
donc oui donc là je dis mais
ça s'est passé durant sa sieste donc ça
s'est passé à 13h30 et là on me répond
oui et là que la rumba là il ya un blanc
je ne sais pas quoi faire je ne sais pas
quoi répéter je suis lundi mais vous me
prévenez trois heures après vous me
prévenez 3 a rappelé m
après vous n'appelez personnes vous ne
prévenez personnes on né le 23 décembre
la crèche femmes à 19 heures il est
16h30 c'est incroyable alors vous
décidez de faire une expertise médicale
et qu'est ce que vous dit le médecin
ouais ouais ouais je dis à mon mari de
pas laisser mes fils comme ça de
l'emmener aux urgences et le médecin il
nous dit que c'est tout frais déjà ils
nous ont dit que que ça peut être une
morsure mais qui a beaucoup d'autres
choses autour voilà il ya des hématomes
il ya il ya sous l'oreille elle a
quadruplé de volume quand vous voyez
c'est pas même pas regarder c'est ce
qu'on sourit jean toussaint voilà avec
ça depuis le 23 des sondés royal a
vraiment cessé c'est quand vous avez vu
ça vous avait éclaté en sanglots quand
j'ai vu les images je me rendais pas
compte
en fait je m'en suis rendu compte
vraiment quand j'ai vu mon fils le soir
quand tu rentrais du travail finalement
et que maintenant je rentrais du travail
je suis parti tout de suite de mon
travail mais après ça il s'en est suivi
voilà je suis allée au commissariat j'ai
fait beaucoup de choses et donc je
rentrais plus tard chez moi j'avais
porté plainte oui c'est porter plainte
contre contre la crèche oui bien sûr oui
bien sûr contre la crèche qu'est ce
qu'on vous a répondu
où ça à la créatrice qui vous ont
répondu les gendarmes ont répondu si
c'était fait mordre durant son sommeil
mais voilà et que par un autre enfant
bah je me suis demandée ce n'était pas
un animal et il y avait personne qu'ils
surveillaient et ben apparemment
non personne personnes étaient là au
moment où aussi ces faits montre mon
fils n'a pas pu enfin il ya clairement
du mensonge mon fils même si il a pu se
faire mardi n'y a pas que ça une fils a
dû pleurer des minutes mais tellement
longue monfils a dû souffrir fin ce que
je leur disais c'est que ce qu'elle me
disait était inaudible et on leur hôtel
sont restés sans voix et voilà à me
regarder
la grande question qu'on se pose la
question qu'on se pose aussi c'est que
les faits se sont déroulés le 23
décembre
oui mais le 18 janvier oui et vous
décidez de parler publiquement
seulement ce week-end pourquoi il avait
attendu tout ce temps j'ai attendu tout
ce temps parce que je suis certainement
trop gentille et a attendu tout ce temps
parce que je pense est clairement que
les choses étaient prises en main
c'était le 23 décembre donc il faut
savoir que les structures collectives
sont fermées pendant les fêtes de noël
donc elle retrouve que leucate qu'on m'a
demandé d'attendre le 4 d'avoir un
contact avec cette fameuse crèche c'est
ja demandent comment qui a demandé de la
mairie service n'est pas bien sûr il
faut savoir qu'il ya des
et voilà il ya toute une structure et
une organisation c'est à dire que les
crèches sont gérées par la mairie et
donc ça revient au service petite
enfance donc moi je m'en suis remise
finalement au service petite enfance
donc je suis allé les voir en détresse
et et voilà j'ai été prise en charge on
m'a contacté mais on m'a simplement
demandé d'attendre le 4 alors que j'ai
attendu le 4 faits et après le cadre
j'ai vu de multiples ennuis des appels
j'ai eu des rendez-vous joconde en
bourrique c'est ça ce que vous êtes loin
c'est ça c'est qu'on m'a demandé de
renoncer à l'avant mais voilà pendant 20
jours vous à tourner en bourrique donc
un moment là ce week-end vous avez
craqué et en fait et en fait j'avais
aucune réponse
je n'ai toujours pas de compte rendu
circonstancié je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé cette journée j'ai demandé
une déclaration d'accident je ne vais
pas à aujourd'hui je ne l'est pas alors
ce qui est plus grave
maintenant c'est ça et c'est pour ça que
ça vous concerne tous tous ceux qui nous
regardent tous ceux qui ont des petits
frères ceux qui ont des petites soeurs
tous ceux qui ont des enfants d'aisance
pour des petits enfants c'est que en
allant plus loin et cette affaire vous
vous rendez compte que votre cas n'est
pas un cas isolé
de quelle manière rendez compte de ça
parce que c'est ça ben c'est pour ça que
vous êtes là ce soir
ouais on s'en rend compte parce qu'on
reçoit on reçoit beaucoup de témoignages
en fait et pour nous pour nous la crèche
c'est l'endroit le plus grisant pour les
enfants c'était l'endroit où l'enfant lé
s'épanouir allait avoir le meilleur
réveil possible pour sa croissance et en
fait on se rend compte
kienan qu'il en est rien je mets pas
tout le monde dans le même sac attention
enfin voila je sais qu'il ya des gens
qui s'inscrivent bien on va virer moi je
le dis on est des gens sont vraiment
excellents pas d'avoir des gens
formidables et d'enfants dans les
crèches et ses 99 % le lendemain après
il ya un autre problème aussi et je le
dis c'est le problème de l'état
il ya un énorme manque de moyens en
crèche ça n'explique pas tout et ça y
est voilà ça n'excuse rien mais il ya un
énorme manque de moyens dans les crèches
et aujourd'hui c'est aussi ce que nous
disent les personnes qui travaillent
dans les crèches mais votre enfant donc
ce qui veut dire que votre enfant
il a fait sa sieste il s'est fait j'ai
envie de dire des cheats est vraiment
décidée c'est le moment c'est pas moi
franchement mais c'est vrai ça c'est
nous le fin mot de l'histoire parce que
c'est ça que demandent tous nos des
spectateurs qu'est ce qui s'est passé
non malheureusement ce qui s'est passé
non je ne les ai jamais eus je n'ai
toujours pas aujourd'hui donc n'ai pas
de contrat je n'ai pas de détails de la
crèche si ce n'est ce qu'on a dit le
jour j donc qu'est-ce qui vous ont déjà
tellement vous ont dit avec s'est fait
mordre par un autre temps mais ils ont
pu identifier l'autre en faut même pour
savoir où là on m'a dit que c'était
toujours le même donc c'est un enfant
que la fois précédente
mais parce que c'était mon devoir c'est
oui n'importe qui même si un enfant
avait mordu une fois là c'est clairement
pas en le faisant je pense qu'on remet
juste la cause sur quelqu'un qui parle
pas donc vous pensez quoi vous fondre
dans l' enfant pourra vous pensez que ça
peut être un adulte que moi je ne sais
pas je pense tout et tout et n'importe
quoi je réfléchis jeu depuis le 23
jeunes tous les soirs je m'endors je me
réveille colza il est où votre votre
enfance il est à la maison avec son père
vous l'avez vous avez arrêté la crèche
pour lui a bien sûr mais vous n'avez pas
trouvé une autre crèche et non j'ai pas
trouvé notre crèche gestion interne
hâtive de la part de la part de
l'amérique a pris entre guillemets le
dossier en main et c'est une solution
qui correspond qui correspond pas à mon
fils parce que c'est pas en équivalent
j'avais eu la directrice de la crèche
non jamais je les rencontrais le 5 jeux
le 5 janvier je les rencontre et à la
demande de la mairie où nous faisons la
même chose
allez vous a dit qu'il était désolé que
qu'elle était désolée mais quoi mais que
il fallait remettre mais là la crèche et
que ça se reproduirait plus et que je
pourrai venir pour surveiller voilà
j'ai dit tout à l'heure vous aviez une
dépression parce qu'il ya plein de gens
qui voulaient pas que vous témoigner de
cette affaire c'est pour ça aussi que
vous à mi temps nous avait mis tant de
temps à poster les photos de votre fils
et a parlé de cette histoire
publiquement sincèrement j'ai fait
confiance j'ai fait confiance je pensais
vraiment au vu des images que que la
chose allait être prise au sérieux et il
en a rien été
donc un moment donné on a aussi je suis
une maman j'ai un coeur et il se passe
des choses dans ma vie
du coup enfin j'ai quand-même un impact
psychologique de tout ça il ya quand
même un impact sur notre quotidien
'aujourd'hui qui fait que j'ai eu besoin
en fait de partager mon expérience et de
dire ce que je vivais et en fait ça a
pris l'engouement que ça a pris je mets
qu'elle est à réparer envie de cela
parce que benjamin castaldi me disais
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que on arrive
on est papa ah oui à l'état de son fils
comme ça la crèche votre mari n'a pas eu
envie de 2 dollar à 1
bah si c'est vraiment un scandale si si
mais moi au téléphone je lui disais
carton sang froid et est ce que les
médecins ont pu déterminer déjà si
c'était des blessures wise et par un
parent enfant aussi potentiellement ça
pouvait être un adulte ans et comme on
le voit bien il a toujours des traces il
a toujours il a il a une grosse
cicatrice là au moment enfin à l'endroit
où c'est au dessus de l'oreille
ouais ça ou c'est vraiment un sens
psychologique a toujours cette race là
et voilà on sent que
encore des douleurs fissile à 15 mois
est le seul mot qui répète à longueur de
journée ces bobos balala voilà donc
c'est pour vous dire c'est pour vous
dire aussi qu'on vit aujourd'hui quoi ça
va être quoi la suite pour vous alors
maintenant vous voulez ça qu'est-ce que
je mets juste savoir ce qui s'est passé
au juste
je suis une maman c'est le minimum
syndical que de me de me dire ce qu'a
vécu mon fils est toujours là ce jour là
moi j'ai passé toutes les vacances à me
demander ce qui s'était passé
g voilà mon fils on me le rend comme ça
moi je suis là l'effectuer à la maison
moi je dois le surveiller si fins ici
s'évanouissent il fait un malaise peu
importe qui peut se passer
on ne sait pas réellement ce qu'il peut
se passer donc nous on le surveille mais
alors je sais que vous souhaitiez
exprimer votre colère au ministre de la
protection de l'enfance
oui adrien taquet pour que ça bouge où
il avait essayé de le joindre
non j'ai pressé de sachez que lui je
vous dis il a essayé de il m'a écrit il
m'a écrit aujourd'hui mes écrits tout à
l'heure qui savait que vous veniez et il
me dit vous recevez de sofia ce soir
dans le petit garçon a été mordu au sein
de sa crèche alors lui apparemment il a
eu donc la version voilà que nous avait
donné qu' apparemment dit qu'il a été
mordue j'espère avant toute chose qu
elle va bien car c'est ça le plus
important
ça c'est que nous avons pris contact
avec les autorités responsables afin de
nous assurer que toutes les procédures
avaient bien été lancée pour comprendre
ce qui s'était passé et éviter que cela
puisse se reproduire à l'avenir la
crèche doit transmettre son rapport
d'incident à la mairie et une visite de
la pmi protection maternelle et
infantile est programmée je crois que
sofia et son mari ont eu des contacts
avec la mairie pour un par ailleurs pour
essayer de trouver une solution pour
l'enfant voilà donc il est apparemment
sur le dossier j'espère que ça va
avancer brou j'espère qu'on va trouver
surtout une nouvelle crèche à votre
enfant j'espère que vous pourrez savoir
ce qui s'est passé et j'espère qu'il va
aller mieux et vraiment tenez nous au
courant
voilà et si on doit faire avancer les
choses n'hésitez pas à nous dire on le
fera bien entendu et on mettra tout
pression voilà qu'on peut mettre pour
que cette affaire avance pour qu'on ait
la vérité sur cette histoire s'arrête
pour que votre fils puisse retrouver une
critique ça arrive parce que si on le
sait ça ça arrive
voilà c'est ccc arrive ça vous est
arrivé et si vous êtes venus ce soir
c'est pour que ça n'arrive plus